you
getting word-of-mouth if you do build a
great experience customers tell each
other about that word-of-mouth is very
powerful Jeff Bezos a billionaire
co-founder of amazon.com if you don't
get positive word-of-mouth and you're
sunk you don't have the big budget to
take out a Superbowl commercial or high
or a celebrity spokesperson you need
people talking about you having a great
product or service isn't enough you need
to make it easy for people to talk about
you think about how busy your customers
are they have opportunities every single
day to promote you to their colleagues
and friends every single day and they
don't why it's not because they don't
love your product or service if they
don't then you need to get to work on
improving your offering it's because you
don't stand out enough they forget about
you you're just okay but when you stand
for something important something people
feel connected to so that people are
proud to be a part of and you make it
easy for them to share because they only
have to remember one word then referrals
start to flow make your message
difficult boring and unremarkable and
nobody will talk about you make your
message one word powerful and important
and people will be delighted to spread
your message at every possible
opportunity
you
you